[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the structure of octopus traveler
presents a huge risk by telling its
story with 8 different characters and
just as many plot lines the RPG has
inevitable peaks and valleys in its
narrative flow the spotlight shifts
between revenge stories rescue missions
and coming-of-age tales at a moment's
notice
it's a lot to balance so going into the
game I had high expectations for the
writing not just the separate stories
unfolding but the presentation and
dialogue tying them all together the
narrative glue so to speak without this
octopus might feel like a collection of
short stories rather than the cohesive
adventure of a multicultural group now
60 hours into my playthrough and
numerous chapters behind me I'm shocked
to find that narrative glue not an
octopus writing but in its combat
right from the outset octopus travelers
combat promises depth no matter which of
the eight characters you start with you
soon discover two of the more impactful
mechanics at play boost points and enemy
shields the former are octa paths
offensive fuel every turn each of your
character is a cruise one boost point
saving these points allows your party to
unleash extra physical attacks or
amplified magical abilities
deciding when to unleash your boost
points becomes a pillar of octa Pat's
combat and the fulcrum of your tactical
decisions this is due in large part to
enemy shields each opponent has a number
of armor layers ranging anywhere from
one to more than ten in some cases foes
can increase their shield rating
throughout the duration of the fight
making it increasingly difficult to
penetrate their armor by discovering an
enemy's weaknesses to certain weapon
types or elemental attacks you can lower
their shield rating with each successive
strike if you manage to deplete an
enemy's shielding entirely you break
them for the remainder of this turn and
the next leaving them open to increased
damage in the meantime when combined
with boost points the act of breaking an
enemy becomes the heart of your
decision-making should you spend
multiple points to stun that enemy with
an upcoming turn or should you save
boost for the next round when you can
unleash it on an already defenseless foe
weighing the benefits of HP damage
versus shield depletion becomes critical
throughout the game if you played many
of this type of RPG before or octopops
gameplay inspirations are probably
fairly obvious stunning enemies is
reminiscent of the persona and Shin
Megami Tensei games while boost points
harken back to bravely default and
bravely second a series that shares two
producers with octopus traveler but
octopus combat is truly impressive
because of its transparency it doesn't
hide much information at all and it
doesn't leave much of the fighting up to
chance yes you'll occasionally miss an
attack because of your low accuracy or
an opponent's high evasion but outside
of these scenarios you'll rarely be
surprised you observe the next turns
attack order and make informed decisions
based on your boost points the enemy's
shields and the characters in your party
it's like playing a game of poker in
which every player's hands is showing
defeat is usually a result of
carelessness or the enemy just having
better cards this isn't to say that
there isn't variety and surprise to be
found in octopus combat in fact they're
abundant there is a slew of variables at
play support abilities job skills and
weapon effects to name a few you can
swap secondary jobs right from the start
menu
buffing each character's passive bonuses
to prepare for the next boss fight this
isn't to mention each character's unique
powers such as Han it's be steaming or
elephant's knowledge of concoction
there are also advanced jobs that
further improve your travelers you begin
your quest as a scholar or a hunter or a
merchant but as the hours roll by and
you face an ever-expanding roster of
enemies your characters evolve into
walking Arsenal's
your characters develop not just through
the writing but the combat as well that
right there is the major reason I grew
to love octopus travelers combat over
the course of my playthrough I have a
tendency to look at games like
individual parts the writing the
soundtrack the art direction but octopus
traveller like my favorite games finds
ways to make those variables work in
concert it tells its story not just
through dialogue and exposition but
through its gameplay as well in other
words the traditional written aspects
only tell half of the story Hana is a
hunter because the developers told us so
but also because she can bide her time
in battles waiting for the perfect
moment to strike and deal massive
amounts of damage elephant's plotline
revolves around helping the sick and his
combat abilities reflect that he removes
party elements he erases status effects
and sometimes in the right circumstances
against the right enemies he weaponized
is the very diseases he usually works to
remove after all he who Kuras can make
it fill story elements like these are
littered throughout octopus combat we
learned cyrus is a scholar because of
his origin story but we believe it
because of the way he studies his
opponents highlighting their weaknesses
and sharing them with his allies his
entire story is centered on the belief
that knowledge should be shared and not
hoarded for one's own personal gain for
the combat to drive that home is
thrilling to see I could keep going down
this road highlighting each character's
combat abilities to reinforce my point
but I think you get it octa bath
traveler is a long game especially if
you complete all four chapters of each
character's narrative and while many of
the quests begin on pretty boring notes
many of them blossom into truly engaging
territory stories involving ethical
dilemmas and personal crises for each of
the travelers but on many levels I think
the game's creators knew they needed
strong gameplay to get you to those
interesting narrative twists they knew
you'd spend the vast majority of your
time fighting so why not tell their
story there in the heat of pitched
battles octa bath travelers combat
that holiest of storytelling mantras
show don't tell as I said before or
octopus eight plot structure runs the
risk of feeling wobbly or disjointed but
its combat has the legs to pull you
through to tell you a story on its own
it defines these characters with verbs
rather than adjectives looking back on
my time with the JRPG I don't see eight
individual quests but one unifying
narrative conveyed not just in what the
developers are telling us but what we
ourselves are doing and I think that's
something future JRPGs should continue
to strive for
you